[Music]
have you been waiting long David
[Music]
good evening from Buckingham Palace
where the nation and the world is
preparing to say goodbye to Elizabeth II
the state funeral will be the biggest
International Event ever held in the UK
attended by Prime Ministers and
presidents princes and kings
foreign
[Music]
Palace where right now a reception is
just ending for more than 500 foreign
dignitaries who will attend tomorrow's
State funeral the list includes
President Biden of the United States
emperor narujito of Japan and Elena
zelenska the wife of the Ukrainian
president
but this week has been about all of us
people of all ages backgrounds and
places who have joined that most British
ship institutions a queue wanting to be
part of something historic and tonight
at 8pm the nation will stop for a
minute's silence to honor the queen
but for now they are still coming in
their thousands some waited in line for
more than 24 hours to pay their respects
at one point the queue stretched back
for nearly five miles a pilgrimage
sustained by frosts of tea sausage rolls
and warm words with new friends
this is the last full day of lying in
state members of the public will be
allowed to file past the coffin until 6
30 tomorrow morning
we are on the eve of the first state
funeral in more than half a century
it will offer a sense of history and
continuity involving traditions and
riots that have evolved over Generations
funeral of Queen Elizabeth II will be
held at Westminster Abbey the resting
place of monarchs and the traditional
site of State funerals for centuries
ahead of the service a funeral
procession will escort the Queen's
coffin to The Abbey from the houses of
Parliament where it's been lying in
state
the coffin draped with the Royal
Standard will be born on the state gun
Carriage of the royal Navy
the Royal Marines will lead the
procession around Parliament Square
behind senior members of the royal
family including her children and the
King will be accompanied on the journey
to the Abbey by the sound of Mast pipes
and muffled drums
the procession will enter the Great West
store of Westminster Abbey at exactly 11
o'clock marking the start of the funeral
service
the queen will be carried past the grave
of the unknown Warrior and down the Nave
of the Abbey
following as they pass under the ornate
gilded entrance of the choir will be the
Archbishop of Canterbury and other
senior clergy
and then the coffin followed by the king
and senior members of the royal family
will be taken to the very heart of the
Abbey and placed in front of the high
altar
members of the royal family will be
seated alongside
behind them in the South transcept heads
of state leaders and royalty from around
the world
sitting opposite holders of the Victoria
and George crosses their counterparts
from the Commonwealth and members of the
nation's highest orders of chivalry
while the Prime Minister former Prime
Ministers and the leaders of Scotland
Wales and Northern Ireland will sit in
the Abbey's choir stalls
the dean of Westminster will lead the
service
lessons will be read by the Prime
Minister and the Secretary General of
the Commonwealth and the sermon will be
given by the Archbishop of Canterbury
at the end of the service the last post
will be sounded from the gothic Splendor
of the lady Chapel resting place of
kings and queens including Elizabeth the
first going back 700 years
a two-minute silence will be observed
throughout the United Kingdom before the
Ravalli is sounded by trumpeters of the
household Cavalry and in the Abbey the
national anthem is sung
the Final Act in the service will be a
procession of the Queen's coffin back
through the choir and along the Nave out
of the Abbey and back onto the state gun
Carriage before it's taken to Windsor
and her final resting place
well I'm joined Now by Sky's Royal
commentator Aleister Bruce and we're
Admiral Jude Terry from the Royal Navy
welcome to both of you tomorrow will be
you know just such an extraordinary
event Alistair with so much grief
attached to it for so many people just
just take us through what we can expect
well it's the last time we can wrap
Elizabeth II with the Splendor of the
nation
and in three parts
she'll be taken to her grave starting
with the state funeral at Westminster
Abbey which has just been explained
and then she will be conveyed to Windsor
Castle
for the committal when she will be
placed in the Royal Vault and then last
thing in the evening there will be the
internment of the queen Prince Philip
with King George VI and the late Queen
Elizabeth and I think what's so special
about all of that is that at the heart
of tomorrow
is a simple Christian soul
who had great faith being conveyed out
of the Splendor of the crown she wore
into the humility of a Christian Soul
ascending to heaven
and we're Admiral the military have been
absolutely Central throughout have they
not and another big role for them
tomorrow yes tomorrow we have the
privilege of our last duty to her
majesty the queen demonstrating our
thanks to her for her dedication and
service to us and for for everything she
did for us and also allow us our
opportunity to demonstrate to his
majesty the king our support and our
gratefulness for his support as we go go
through uh through the rest of our
careers we have about 3 000 people will
be on Parade in London tomorrow and
about a thousand people in in Windsor
those are made up of uh the Army the
Navy and the Air Force but also
Commonwealth Nations will be represented
and we have approximately 175
Commonwealth Nations being represented
tomorrow the Navy has a key part to play
with the state gun Carriage obviously
but it the key thing for all of us is
that we've worked as a team delivering
what his majesty wants to see tomorrow
and what the nation wants and it's been
incredible as the person in charge for
the Royal Navy to be able to watch Young
Sailors War Marines people from the RFA
are all Fleet auxiliary join as under my
uh training team and then to watch them
you'll have seen the rehearsals have
watched them working with their
colleagues from across the world and
across the other services
well it is the Royal Navy is it not that
pulls this state gun Carriage it's a you
know really critical moment you know
what's the history of that then Alistair
well when Queen Victoria died in 1901
her train was so late arriving at
Windsor that the horses that were due to
take the gun Carriage up the hill
got cold and kicked their traces and had
to be taken off the guncoat The King was
distraught
and his niece's husband who was an
admiral like the fine lady here
was Prince Louisa battenberg and he
suggested that the naval root liners
take the ropes that were holding the
crowd back and attach it to the gun
carriage and take Queen Victoria to St
George's Chapel Windsor and he was so
grateful that he said forevermore it
will be a privilege for the Royal Navy
to carry their Sovereign to her final
resting place we will certainly see that
tomorrow won't we stay there both of you
because earlier this afternoon President
Biden also made that visit to See Her
Majesty's coffin let's get the very
latest now from Dominic wyghorn who
joins us the lying in state just one
part of a busy schedule certainly for
the president and he's one of more than
500 foreign dignitaries who've been in
Buckingham Palace and we can see the
outriders beginning to to take those
people away Dominic
yourself yeah I think that event is is
now over another extraordinary event in
in um at least a week of them 500
foreign dignitaries and it's hard to
remember a time when that number of
world leaders Prime Ministers royalty
gathered in in one place in one city if
it's ever happened before or if it will
ever happen again and that followed
these extraordinary scenes we saw
earlier in Westminster Hall here where
we saw uh presidents uh royalty kings
and queens join ordinary people who had
queued up uh the the vip's got Fast
Track access but they they joined also
to pay their respects their last
respects to the queen as she uh at lay
in State uh here and of course those
world leaders are here for the funeral
tomorrow and what's interesting about
this is of course the huge logistical
challenge that has faced officials here
what do you do with that number of world
leaders 100 heads of government amongst
them 20 uh Royal figures and 500 foreign
dignitaries how do you get them from
from wherever they are in London to
Westminster Abbey and what you do with
them afterwards this is my report on
this great convergence of royalty and
dignitaries currently gathering in
London
as the people have continued to file
through Westminster Hall behind them a
steady stream of foreign dignitaries the
kings of Spain and Sweden
the first lady of Ukraine clearly moved
and presidents from around the world
U.S President Joe Biden joining mourners
to pay his respects
she was the same in person as her image
decent honorable
and all about service it's a loss that
leaves a giant hole
and uh sometimes you think you'll never
you'll never overcome it
but as I've told the king
she's going to be with him every step of
the way every minute every moment and
that's a reassuring notion
one of a hundred heads of governments
Gathering here from Emperors to Crown
princes there are 20 Royals among 500
foreign guests
prime minister of 19 here
they know this will never be repeated
because a unique era is drawing to a
close another beginning not least for
the Commonwealth whose leaders met King
Charles earlier today
on the eve of the funeral a prediction
from the president of Trinidad and
Tobago that under the new king more and
more commonwealth countries will give up
the Monarch as head of state as the
times continued changing there is a
feeling now after all these years that
The Sovereign should really be the
people
and to have a sovereign from a country
that is far removed not only
geographically but culturally
right might not necessarily be the best
thing at this time of the nation's
development
so I think that perhaps the process will
begin speeding up in various territories
what will be your emotions what will be
going through your
your mind as in Cincinnati tomorrow
looking back on the era I thought well I
really would have to carry my
handkerchief with me because it's quite
possible that I need shed a tear for the
queen
at this funeral death will be the great
leveler whatever the rank dignitaries
all arriving in coach class bust in from
Chelsea's Royal Hospital
being corralled in a glorified holding
pen and then put on buses is not what
world leaders are used to but it is the
only option say officials who've never
had to deal with so many foreign
dignitaries all at the same time
noses are already out of joints
resentment reportedly that the US
president will be an exception able to
attend in Cadillac one it is a
diplomatic minefield
but as leaders and dignitaries filed
into Buckingham Palace this evening a
sense of the enormity of this occasion
the world's most influential and
powerful people gathering together to
pay a final tribute to a monarch loved
like no other
Dominic wagorn Sky News Westminster
well I'm joined by Lord Boateng who was
the UK's first black cabinet minister
and a former British High Commissioner
to South Africa welcome to you and we're
about to see all those dignitaries
depart are we not the buses are lined up
for them they're on buses
extraordinarily stuff but you know
reflect on the meeting in there the
importance of this now for King Charles
and you know why everybody's decided to
come
I think first of all this is an
indication of just how much her late
Majesty meant to the world but to the
world's leadership too she was a great
convener she brought people together she
embodied the nation and yet she
transcended politics
so whatever a country's relationship
with the British government they tended
to have a positive relationship with the
Monarch and once saw that if for events
like our national day out in the field
in British posts all over the world it
is the Queen's birthday
and so people came to our national day
in greater numbers than to any other
because in coming to our event they were
celebrating something very personal to
the queen and she meant something to
them so a great convener and this is a
testament to her success over so many
years what does this mean for Britain
right now can we read anything into it
or is this simply about our Monarch I
think it's about transition
and I don't think we should be
frightened of transition
um King Charles has been around on the
international scene as someone with
great concerns around climate around the
environment around human rights he is
well known and so it's not as if they
were meeting a stranger but he is of a
different generation so this is a moment
of transition but it's not a moment of
danger it's a time in which we're we are
entitled to celebrate all the queen gave
to the nation and to the world but to
look forward to a developing and
evolving relationship which where King
Charles will embody this nation its
values and what it represents in the
modern world the Commonwealth which was
Tiny when she was coronated and now is
big
is a central part of the people who are
there what are your hopes for the
Commonwealth as it goes forward and and
the role of the Monarch to in that I
think it's important to remember that
the queen is to a very large extent the
originator of the Commonwealth ideal uh
it grew during her Reign she propelled
that growth she kept it together at
moments of peril and there have been
moments of peril uh particularly around
South Africa and apartheid and the
British government's role in that regard
and yet it was the queen with her
support for the Commonwealth with her
sense of its non-racial multi-ethnic
nature the relationship she developed
with Nelson Mandela it it was the queen
who kept that together but at the same
time the Commonwealth freely decided to
make King Charles her successor this
wasn't something that was forced on them
it was done out of recognition not just
of the Queen's personal wish but also of
King Charles King Charles's Fitness for
that purpose as someone who'd taken a
deep and abiding interest in the
Commonwealth and also on those issues
that affect it and what are those issues
the environment undoubtedly climate
change he has played an enormously
important role in that in that regard
also and importantly values around
inclusivity and diversity you know King
Charles was at the Forefront in terms of
celebrating diversity and addressing
issues of of disadvantage before it
became fashionable and I think the wider
World recognizes that lobotang thank you
very much indeed thank you we're
certainly keeping on those dignitaries
so many of them that have been in
Buckingham Palace this evening but right
now let's head to Dermot Monaghan at
Windsor
Anna many thanks well this afternoon
prince Andrew paid tribute to her
majesty the queen calling her mummy and
saying I will forever hold you close to
my heart then on Friday he was seen
again in military uniform as he stood
vigil with his siblings over the Queen's
coffin at Westminster Hall well I'm
joined Now by our Royal correspondent
Laura bundock and Laura what else did he
say in his statement it's a really
interesting statement for a number of
reasons he is the last of the Queen's
children to make a statement and the
only one to use the word mummy in that
statement which in itself interesting I
think if you look at the photo he
released in accompanying this statement
it is the most intimate of images you
can see in 1960
um in March 1960 the queen cradling him
closely taken by the society Society
photographer Cecil Beaton and what an
intimate image perhaps the most intimate
photo we have seen from all the photos
that the family have been released
releasing it was often reported how
close he was to the queen and certainly
this photo does suggest this cherished
deep affection and the words too I'll
just talk you through a little chunk of
this statement he says mommy your love
for a son your compassion your care your
confidence I will treasure forever I
have found your knowledge and wisdom
infinite with no boundary or containment
I will miss your insights advice and
humor and he adds as our book of
experiences closes another opens and I
will forever hold you close to my heart
with my deepest love and gratitude and I
will tread gladly into the next with you
as my guide and again a very personal
tribute there real sense of his loss of
how bereft he's feeling at the moment
but don't forget you know prince Andrew
had to step down from all Royal roles
and duties back in 2019 the queen
stripped him of all his honorary
military titles and he was only allowed
to wear a uniform the visual
um as a special sort of occasion as a
special event
um it was all kind of in if we remember
back to the Jeffrey Epstein Scandal his
involvement in that is what brought it
about earlier this year he settled the
case with Virginia Jeffrey out of court
don't know how much an undisclosed some
meant to be a very very big sum though
what does this statement say it shows
how berefty is perhaps his attempts of
rehabilitating himself back into the
royal family what role there might be
for him what duties might lie ahead is
very very unclear at the moment if any
at all Laura many thanks Laura Banda
Carl correspondent well of course the
queen will be buried here at Windsor
Castle in Saint George's Chapel
alongside her husband and her parents
George the sixth and Elizabeth the Queen
Mother
after the end of the funeral service
outside Westminster Abbey's Great West
door the Queen's coffin will be mounted
on the state gun Carriage of the royal
Navy
a huge procession involving members of
the royal family will travel down
Whitehall
hundreds of Representatives of armed
forces from across the services and
Commonwealth Realms will march across
horse guards and onto the mall
the queen will then be drawn past
Buckingham Palace for one final time
before the procession Armed Forces
lining the route arrives at Wellington
Arch
there by Hyde Park Corner the coffin
will be transferred to the state hearse
and the funeral cortesh will leave for
Windsor
it will travel through West London
beyond the limits of the capital and
past Heathrow Airport before arriving at
Windsor Castle
there a new procession will begin at the
long walk and move into the castle
the hearse scores of soldiers courtiers
and the royal family will process to the
steps of Saint George's Chapel the very
Church where the Queens say goodbye to
her husband Prince Philip
inside the royal family foreign royalty
the Prime Minister realm Prime Ministers
and Knights of the Garter will gather
for a committal service led by the dean
of Windsor
in the historic Chapel choir at the end
of the service the Queen's most senior
adviser the Lord Chamberlain will
ceremonially break his wand of office
and place it on the coffin
and then one last Act the national
anthem Will Be Sung God Save the King
marking the final moment of her nation's
farewell to her majesty Queen Elizabeth
II
well I'm joined now by the author and
contemporary historian Sir Anthony
Selden and Sir Anthony so then went to
Castle Saint George's Chapel will be the
Queen's final resting place as it is for
so many other members of her family
indeed some 25 members of the royal
family are buried there including 10
monarchs incredibly and it's now the
regular final resting place of the
Monarch in this extraordinary Castle
here
which is the longest continuously
inhabited Royal residence going back to
1066 and chosen because of the river we
the the story is All About The River
Thames the Royal uh family Story coming
all the way wending all the way up to
London here chosen because it was the
defensive point defending London from
attack from the West and then extended
uh in 1100 and since 1100 all monarchs
have at different times been here
Charles the first imprisoned here but
also buried uh here in 1649 after he was
executed in Whitehall Palace so full of
of History uh history of the Royal
Family An extraordinarily special and
for the last 10 years of her life this
is where Queen Elizabeth II lived but
interestingly given how much she favored
Windsor Castle Queen Victoria is is not
buried in the chapel but in Frogmore
Mausoleum uh
that was Victoria all over Victoria
always did things her own way when her
husband died she went into Retreat when
Queen Elizabeth's second's husband died
she was straight back on her juicy uh
Queen Victoria lying in state in her
beloved Osborne house in the Isle of
Wight
and the Queen Elizabeth II doing things
in a much more expected way uh
I want to talk more about of course Her
Majesty the Queen's life in a moment or
two but let's um listen to the Queen's
first public speech that was back in
1940 as a teenager a radio address to
the children of the Commonwealth many of
them living away from home of course
because of the war and then to one of
her last appearances on television I
think you know what it is earlier this
year during the the Platinum Jubilee
thousands of you in this country have
had to leave your homes and be separated
from your fathers and mothers
My Sister Margaret Rose and I feel so
much for you
as we know from experience what it means
to be away from those we love most of
all
to you living in new surroundings we
send a message of true sympathy and at
the same time we would like to thank the
kind people who have welcomed you to
their homes in the country
oh
never mind
[Music]
perhaps
you would like a marmalade sandwich
I always keep one for emergencies
so do I
I keep mine in here
but later
here we go
and uh Selden is still with me Sir
Anthony what's interesting that I think
what strikes most people in terms of the
the two clips we've used obviously the
amount of time between them but the
change in the Queen's voice and that
tells us something doesn't it receive
pronunciation back in 1940 those clipped
tones and uh much more like the rest of
us speak come by the time of Paddington
if I can put it that way well it shows
her extraordinary power of adaptation
doesn't it she moved with the times and
that's why she remained enduringly loved
and popular but also I haven't seen that
1941 before there you could see her
ability to empathize even as a 14-15
year old who was saying she could
imagine what people young people felt
being away from their families and and
she felt it you can feel there is a
thoroughly authentic person even though
she's barely a teenager and then and
then you fast forward some 80 years to
the Platinum Lee and there she's still
got that ability to be funny and
empathetic and communicate with people
with children and people of all ages I
mean that's a Sublime gift in anybody
but to have that gift as a monarch wow I
mean that's really special and just
looking back to the the 1940s and
there's the Her Majesty the queen of
course in service and surrounding is
this in a way then the the final end of
the post-war period with the the death
of her majesty the queen that that link
now broken
I think it is I really do and it was
significant that in one of her greatest
ever broadcast during covid and who of
course did the nation look to during
covid for consolation and Direction they
look to the to the Monarch not to the
prime minister they looked at the
Monarch what was her cultural reference
point back to Vera Lynn back to wilmese
again so I think that is a closing down
of the second world war in a way the
long second world war and Britain's role
as a as one of the great powers in the
second world war and the Empire it's all
coming to an end now brexit also another
factor in that we are at the dawn of a
new age and we have to find a new place
in the world and a new justification for
Britain uh claiming its Authority in the
world so Anthony do stay with us but for
the time being thank you very much
indeed well of course in the past 10
days the King has moved from Edinburgh
to Belfast and Cardiff and then back to
London greeting his new subjects he's
been met with warmth and affection but
once that wave of grief and emotion has
passed so might some of the good will
towards the new monarch our Royal
correspondent Rhiannon Mills reports
God Save the King
[Music]
for a man who always knew this time
would come the cameras allowed in like
never before so we could understand how
he felt about her and what he's taken on
as the queen herself did with such
unswerving devotion
I too now solemnly pledge myself
throughout the remaining time God grants
me
to uphold the constitutional principles
at the heart of our nation
got pheasant and wood British High
Commission
Barbados
private secretary for four years and
believes the man he knows well has acted
quickly to squash suggestions he'll be a
meddling Monarch as king he will do
things differently it's a very different
job but I think we'll still see those
those same instincts that same desire to
want to use his role appropriately but
to use his role in a way which makes a
difference to to this country makes a
difference in the Commonwealth uh and
and does does a service I Charles Prince
of Wales there are no rules for how he
should Reign but he had the best of
teachers the queen guiding him towards
the role that would eventually be his
it shaped a man who always keeps his
police officers on their toes the
walkabouts this week coming naturally as
he showed us he wasn't just going to do
what was expected but what matters to
him has an additional duty
less formally recognized but to be no
less diligently discharged
it is the duty to protect the diversity
of our country on the world stage she
will be a hard act to follow very rarely
putting a foot wrong
the rolling cameras haven't always been
as forgiving for her son inkwells and
pens bearing the brunt and in some ways
showing why the new king and the
institution still has work to do
and why the new monarch
he did his family
it's going to be potentially difficult
for King Charles but what we have seen
this week is how the entire family also
want to step up to help in every one of
their tributes to the queen they also
mentioned their brother their father
their uncle and their support for the
new king publicly he has United them but
it is still the queen that has brought
the world together now that heaviest of
responsibilities rests with her son
finally it is his time to lead Rihanna
Mills Sky News in central London
answer Anthony Selden is still with me
while Sir Anthony has been often
observed over the past 10 days we are
entering we're in a new era how will
Charles approach the role well he's
shown already that he is fully up for it
he's had the longest induction of
anybody on Earth 70 years waiting for it
he's got lots of ideas but he's also
very clear that he's not going to enter
the political arena in one sense he
doesn't need to because we all know what
he thinks about the environment and
about local crafts and arts and
communities so he doesn't need to but he
clearly wants to carry on that Heritage
to the monarchy to still represent the
entire United Kingdom that's going to be
a big struggle for him with Ireland with
Scotland keeping the Commonwealth up
together but I think he's made a really
good start I mean it's such a tough act
taking over from his mother you never
want to take over as a leader from
somebody who is much loved who everyone
thinks is great because
how can you compare when she started off
she was young and beautiful we felt
protective towards her you know there he
is a 73 year old but I think he's done
well
Sir Anthony for the time being thank you
very much indeed well from Windsor
Castle now back to Buckingham Palace and
Anna
I'll miss her hugely the heartfelt words
from the Archbishop of Canterbury as he
prepares for his role at the Queen's
State funeral Justin Welby also told me
that world leaders should learn from
Queen Elizabeth's example he will give
the sermon in Westminster Abbey tomorrow
in front of a global audience which
could reach billions
I feel very privileged to be there not
pleased to be there because
we would all prefer that this had not
happened but we're all going to miss and
grieve
for the queen
but
it's a huge privilege to be able to take
part in this focused on the family first
because this is a family
saying goodbye at a funeral
to someone they loved do you get a sense
of of national mourning I know you've
been down to see the crowds queuing it
outside Westminster hall for example you
know is is there a shared experience
we're having here oh yes yes yes yes yes
I think it is a genuinely shared
experience it's an experience of grief
for many deep grief
but also mixed with an experience of
immense thankfulness
uh talking to people yesterday in the
queue and earlier in the week
listening to them they said oh I I'd say
why have you come
I wanted to say thank you
and that was I found that deeply moving
he was the longest serving Prince of
Wales this country has ever seen is it
is it too much do you think to expect
somebody to to take on this role in
their later years no
he is a man of very great intelligence
humility
thoughtfulness commitment to service
and he's been thinking about this role
for very very many years indeed a few
days ago on
Wednesday at the receiving at
Westminster Hall
there was
an almost tangible sense
of the of the roles the weight of the
roles settling on him and him rising to
gather that
and hold it as the queen did
such extraordinary tributes about her
majesty her thoughtfulness and her
kindness has really stood out to the
people I've spoken to and you've had
that experience yourself haven't you
from her yes very much so I I the thing
that there's been all kinds of things
but her capacity
to put one at onesies
I remember being at um
a
meal
with she asks a bishop in January every
year to go each Sunday to Sandringham
she used to do this and
preach Saturday evening quite often they
go for a barbecue
in January in North Norfolk in the um
in the woods in a cabin in the woods
and she has loads of house guests and
one of them that it's very relaxed
and there's no electricity in you all
day the table she does everyone knows
the table
and I was there thinking feeling this is
I'm going to wake up in a minute you
know this can't be real
and one of the house guests said to me
oh um Archbishop could you just put the
candlesticks on the table then like the
candles
something for my school days just
rang a bell
and I went over to her and said man
would it be helpful if I put the
candlesticks on the table and the
candles and she's there was a little
twinkle in eye because she knew what was
going on and she said I don't think
Prince Philip would like that at all
and she was they were just trying to get
me into trouble but it was so funny
she was so relaxed and fun and just a
very very lovely human being
many people did say that her will meet
again messaged during um covid got them
through the pandemic did you get the
sense at all that she's just leaving us
at just the just the wrong moment as we
head into this difficult winter which
many people are frightened about
um I think people are very frightened
about the future
and for many we mustn't forget you know
we've had 10 days of mourning but um
we've got the funeral tomorrow official
national morning ends I think
um day after tomorrow
but
that hasn't bought more money into
people's pockets
people are still going to food banks
during this time
struggling to work out
how to make the budget
last make the pay last as long as the
month
or the benefit last songs of the month
and people are frightened but
I am absolutely that the extraordinary
thing about the Royal Family
is that they knew that
and they are deeply aware of it
and yes there's going to be changes
and the next few months may be very
difficult many many people will be
but from the point of view of the head
of state there's been a seamless
transition there's not going to be a gap
there there will be the hardship but
there's not going to be the gap
when was the last time you saw her
it was end of June early July
I can't quite remember the exact date
and I went along with
um something to give her actually a a
cross of nails like this these nails are
a symbol of the cathedral they fell from
the roof of the medieval Cathedral as it
burned in the great Blitz it's been used
as a symbol of reconciliation and peace
building around the world and she's had
such an influence on peacemaking and
police building and drawing people
together that I we gave her that gift
and I was privileged to give it to her
I came back and I said to my wife oh
we needn't worry I'm I'm not going to
have to
do a coronation
uh it'll be my successor who does that
she's so fit
and memory was so acute her observation
so perceptive
you got the benefit of 70 years of
accumulated wisdom in government
and in leadership and you know
not only her family but I think every
senior politician every
Archbishop will will will mess up you
sound like you will after hugely
you talked about the work the queen did
in peace and conciliation quite frankly
and we will watch all these people
arriving from around the world on Monday
and there is a sense even now that she's
unifying the globe in this don't you
think yes her conciliation and peace
building was not
the sort of Hands-On
way of doing it it was inspirational
and symbolic that made people look at
things a bit differently especially
within the Commonwealth
and work behind the scenes as we know
now from the time of the apartheid
regime in South Africa and
you know being very conscious of the
symbolic importance of what the British
government did at that time for example
um but she's going to unite more global
leaders
possibly than at any point in human
history
I hope and pray that they will reflect
on their own leadership and think
do I want my legacy
to be in the bank balance
of Earth
or in the words of Jesus who she
followed so Faithfully do I want to
store up treasure in heaven
and which she has done in her way of
service are you saying that they could
learn from her oh absolutely
um
absolutely I think there are
extraordinary wonderful leaders coming
I hope they find what they hear and see
and think about
a moment where they say to themselves
I would really like people to look on me
in the way that they look on her
we know they should be buried alongside
her late husband she'll be reunited with
her family her father her mother her
sister who are a tight-knit family did
she really believe that she would see
them again
yes
how did she express that to you
not only to me but in her in that great
covid broadcast but in her Christmas
broadcasts as well
she was a deeply faithful and Faith
filled
under monstrative
quiet
Christian who trusted
in the faithfulness of God
in the words we often use
that she would and her family rest in
peace and rise in glory
it's at the heart of Christian faith
she at peace now
yes
and should the nation take comfort from
that
I think the nation should take Hope from
that not just comfort
but hope for themselves it's a gift
that she knew that came from God
in whom she believed and trusted in whom
she served and who gave her the strength
to be what she was
the Archbishop of Canterbury there
speaking to me and as you can see the
lion State continues inside Westminster
Hall
the French President Emmanuel macron and
his wife Brigitte as you can see the
latest world leaders to pay their
respects
foreign
still being allowed in people had
earlier been asked not to join the queue
which is at Tower Bridge now but a
decision on ending that queue has not
yet been taken
foreign
hours left now of lying in state and the
the people still queuing as you can see
Victoria Gardens there now Westminster
well let's bring in our skies Royal
commentator Alistair Bruce and uh rear
Admiral Jude Terry from the Royal Navy
uh joining me also here Nancy O'Neill
who is uh one of those who's been
invited in fact to the service tomorrow
um Aleister first of all let's talk
about the Archbishop of Canterbury plays
a central role in a number of ways
tomorrow
um talking there about how her majesty
was deeply faithful and faith-filled and
firmly believed that she will be
reunited with her husband
well he had a very close relationship
with the queen and I think because the
queen was Supreme governor of the Church
of England and he was head really of the
Anglican communion across the world
it's a very interesting time I think for
him to now Encompass faith for the
nation and I think in your talk with him
particularly in your question about the
queen being at peace he took that
exactly as one would most want somebody
in his position to do I think for the
queen it always seemed that Faith was so
special to her because in almost every
part of her life
she was elevated Above the Rest
but I think for her own peace of mind
the place where she felt just like us
all was before God
and I think that made it easier for her
to endure such a long period of being
number one
because I think that particularly in the
way she found reassurance and I think
she took this from her parents too
in the faithfulness that she had which
the Archbishop discussed I think that
was a great guide to her and the
Archbishop I am sure amongst many others
in the church and other Faith leaders
that the queen has met
we're able to reassure the queen in that
process and if you believe as Christians
do in eternal life then the archbishop's
quite right to say this is in its own
way a rejoicing time for her soul
we know also
um
she loved the detail of the military
didn't she um she felt real closeness to
them not least because of her family
members who had served and there were
very many of them and what was her
relationship specifically with the Royal
Navy which is the uh which is the force
that you obviously I remember of so
obviously the queen was the first female
to serve in the in the armed forces when
she joined the auxiliary auxiliary
territorial Squadron so she had a really
close relationship with the military she
was a colonel in Chief of over 50 uh
regiment organizations ships
Etc so she had a really close
relationship from our perspective she
was the daughter of a sailor she was the
wife of a sailor she was the mother of
sailors and she she also um you know
Prince William also serves some time in
the Royal Navy and therefore she
understood it from that perspective she
was hugely supportive of everything we
did and from our perspective the ships
uh Queen Elizabeth Lancaster her ships
that she sponsored she was was always
really interested not only in what they
were doing on operations which was
incredible but also the families of the
people who were on those ships and every
year in her Christmas message she would
reflect on all of the Armed Forces where
they were serving on operations around
the world and be incredibly grateful for
us as well as our nursing colleagues and
those in in the emergency services who
would he would have to work on work over
those holidays so from our perspective
she was one of us she lived as a naval
wife in her early in her early marriage
to Prince Philip in Malta and declared
that that was one of her happiest times
of how she lived and was able to bestow
on Prince Philip in 2011 the honor of
being the Lord hi Admiral which she was
incredibly proud to do to him to honor
his his Service as well and his his
Affinity with the service but
um tomorrow is all about all three
services working together as one team to
deliver it for for her majesty the New
Zealand prime minister Jacinda ardern
said she had grown not never knowing
anything other than the queen saying
there was nothing ever that suggested to
me that I couldn't be a woman in
leadership
um you know watching on from her majesty
here you are now
um the first woman to hold flag rank of
the royal Navy
um I'm not suggesting it's going to be
the same for you but um you know we
should is she a role model for all of us
incredible role model for all of us and
actually no matter what your gender
obviously from a from being a female she
was incredibly inspirational as as is
her daughter as a as our other members
of her family I've been privileged
enough to meet meet the queen twice
um in absolutely incredible but also
just in terms of allowing everybody to
be the best they could be she encouraged
everybody no matter where they were from
no matter what regiment they were in no
matter what rank they were in no matter
whether they were RAF uniform a Navy
uniform or Army so absolutely and a real
role model for leadership for compassion
for dedication and we could all do well
to learn that I don't know there's a
real Pride for all of those uh taking
part in uh in Monday's event certainly
well let's bring in now Nancy O'Neill a
nurse from Bradford and one of 183
special honors recipients who's been
invited to attend tomorrow's State
funeral at Westminster Abbey
um first of all how are you feeling
about that a little a little overwhelmed
perhaps uh yes uh definitely overwhelms
one of the words it's still very surreal
I don't think it'll feel real until I'm
actually there and what problem until
after I've come out and reflected upon
it because it does feel very much as if
it's this is something that's happening
to somebody else
um but I was I was just reflected
earlier I I got off the train from Leeds
this afternoon stood on Victoria to
platform and the man that stood next to
me was one of the 183 as well
and I recognized him because there'd
been an article in the newspaper that he
and I were the subject of the article
when there was a picture of him and I
thought sure that's him so I asked him
and he said yes and I recognize you too
so yeah amazing so what did you think
when you first got the invitation and
the point is that you're a birthday
honors recipient of the summer are you
not that's right yeah and because we
haven't been to the investiture yet so
we haven't received our award in person
and that that's what the man from the
cabinet office said that because we
hadn't received it yet uh we were going
to invite a number of people he didn't
say how many we didn't know it was 183
at that time so he said that would I be
interested in attending and when I
stopped saying wow really are you sure
um I said yes absolutely I'd be
interested in attending so that was um
but there were three thoughts went
through my head the first one was
oh maybe because the queen has now died
the king doesn't want us to have the
award maybe he can change his mind
um the second one was what an odd plan
to ring me to tell me the date for going
to collect my award I thought they were
a little bit busy then the third one was
is this a hoax is this somebody I know
that's making this up under that so at
the hand he just said well somebody will
be in touch shortly from the Royal
household
and then four or five days went by and
nothing came and I thought I'm
increasingly this is a hoax but then it
wasn't so here I am and it was your
Sterling work as a nurse for 41 years
plus your Sterling work during the
pandemic trying to get key workers and
NHS staff tested one of the first test
centers up and running and we know that
the queen felt very grateful to all of
those who'd worked during the pandemic
she told us in uh in that we'll meet
again
um you know a tape that I mentioned with
the Archbishop said do you feel you know
grateful to her that she recognized the
hard work you were all doing
absolutely it's not just the recognition
that she gave then either I think it's
you know that came to the farm that
speech was was quite important to people
that were working not just in health
service but in Health and Social care
because they're you know they were
working incredibly hard as well but I
think you know she was a clear Advocate
previously of the NHS and she you know
supported and encouraged people to to to
follow the rules and to do the right
thing and and we were working very hard
in the background and and yes I worked
in in Bradford district and Craven
delivering the the Corpus some of the
covert response but it was the people
that are unseen and unheard that
delivered that that service you know
down to the the cleaners and the
volunteers that were marshalling there
were all sorts of people I I was
fortunate in that obviously
I was recognized for that but it's on
behalf of other people
Nancy I hope you get to sit next to the
the other 183 the man you met on the
train
um thank you both uh all of you thank
you very much indeed that's a head now
to dermud ahead of that minutes silence
at 8pm
Anna thank you very much indeed well as
Anna was just saying at eight o'clock
precisely a minute silence will be
observed around the country to remember
her majesty Queen Elizabeth II so
Anthony Selden the historian is with me
now and Sir Anthony just explained to us
what is the the origin of a national
moment of silence the first world war
was so vast in World Experience over 20
million dead that when it was happening
people were wondering how can we
possibly mark this and to find something
that transcends a national difference
and language difference with silence
everyone can understand you don't need
language you don't need nationality to
understand that it's a moment where
everyone can come together and be silent
and in reverence of the enormous number
of dead compounded by those who died
from the Spanish Flu some 50 million and
who died in 1980 1990 1920. so in 1919
on the 11th of November by the cenotaph
there was the first two-minute silence
and that took it took the whole people
liked it and still more so after the
second world war it embedded it further
it's a moment where the nation comes
together to commemorate those who have
died but also as now when there's a
great figure a truly extraordinary
figure who touched the hearts of
everybody
and so until it is both a collective act
but also an individual one where the
individual reflects as well as part of
that Collective yes I mean nobody knows
exactly it's so private uh what people
are thinking about and reflecting about
but those who have as many had with
covid lost dear ones loved ones since
the queen died 17
000 people have died in this country are
often much younger than the queen so
there's been a lot of personal grief
going on just in in the few days since
she died it's a moment a time for us to
to get in touch with our deepest selves
and to find an inner resolution and in a
acceptance uh to to be at one with
ourselves as well as being at one with
everybody else a form of meditation
almost well
I've practiced meditational my life or
most of it and and have drawn great
strength from that inner sense of
Stillness and just collecting yourself
coming to yourself it helps you to to to
to to Really make the most of your life
as this will do
well uh welcome to those channels who
have just joined us here on Sky News so
we are about to observe a national
moment of reflection
to mourn the death of the late Queen
Elizabeth II and reflect of course on
her life and Legacy it's a minute
silence that will be observed up and
down the country these some of the
locations obviously in central London
where people will pause reflect
stay silent for just a minute after we
hear the Chimes from the clock tower of
Big Ben clearly those people those
thousands of people who are in that
Queue at the moment to enter Westminster
Hall to pay their last respects to her
majesty the Queen the hundreds of
thousands of others who have done that
themselves perhaps now returned home
will also join in that so we have
cameras in many locations up and down
the country to observe the silence in
Downing Street the Prime Minister will
be seen
we'll be in Blackpool we'll be in
Northern Ireland will be in York and of
course we'll be in central London
were there
I mean it's silence to observe and
knowing
The Life and Legacy of a Majesty Queen
Elizabeth II
[Applause]
and here at Windsor Castle
the crowds
gathered observing them in its silence
and then as you can see there in so many
other locations around the country
ripples of Applause three cheers
in Forker
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
a striking
Blackpool Tower there lit up in red
white and blue with the heart and the
Union flag
right in the center this uh the scene
a joke Minster
and Central London the queues
still many thousands of people waiting
their last chance
to say their goodbyes to him I just did
the queen as she lies and stayed in
Westminster Hall the queues continuing
throughout the night
well Becky Johnson is in Derby for a
cinder Becky a silence and then in so
many places
cheers Applause what's been happening
there
well this is one Community like so many
across the country that has chosen to
come together to mark that National
minute of Silence to share their
thoughts during this period of national
mourning and really to share their
Reflections we're now going to hear from
a band this is going to be an evening in
celebration of the life and reign of
Queen Elizabeth I can bring in Sally
what have been your Reflections just
then during that that moment of silence
but also during the course of this
period of national mourning well it's a
somber somber time and we're all south
of England
uh reflecting on you know all the past
memories I think
um mum came to the pub in 1953 and she
showed the coronation on in the room
and we're now going to hear songs from
the seven decades or so of the reign of
Queen Elizabeth it's going to be a
moment for the community to reflect and
I know you say you've had members of the
community who've been to London to join
the queue but also people choosing to
remember the queen in their own quiet
way here in Derby yes that's right yeah
a lot of people are I think are
reflecting on things that are personal
to them when they've had moments of
meeting her or things like that
and and for yourself I think many people
have perhaps been taken by surprise by
how personally emotional they've been
yeah it is I think people have been
quite surprised how many have made the
journey to London and queued for 24
hours
all right thank you so much for talking
to us so yeah this community will be
spending the evening now uh listening to
a concert taking some quiet time to
reflect on the life and reign of Queen
Elizabeth II
Becky Johnson there and Derby uh thank
you very much indeed Becky well uh still
got the author and contemporary
historian Sir Anthony Selden with me and
Sir Anthony just what did you do you
make of that
intensely moving wasn't it wherever
people were there's something about
silence that brings us all together
words can so often separate us with our
different opinions and shades and
ideologies but in silence she brought
the whole nation the Commonwealth many
people in the whole world together
recognizing our common humanity and
remembering
somebody whose entire life was dedicated
to goodness and to Servant leadership to
looking after others to sing the best in
other people we've all lost somebody I
thought that was just perhaps as
stunning a moment as we've seen
and then afterwards we we heard it here
didn't we on the streets of Windsor the
Applause the cheering it's almost the
antidote it's it's cathartic I guess I
mean Shades there also of clapping for
the NHS and and that sense of coming
together to support the best but but
clearly this will never happen again
this is something that we will never see
again in our lifetimes probably
certainly never an event like tomorrow
the biggest
event the biggest Gathering of great and
good and powerful people perhaps in
world history happening tomorrow
something very very special here on the
streets of Windsor wandering around
there's a sense of building and building
momentum I felt the same thing wandering
amongst the crowds Gathering earlier in
the week to to to walk past the coffin a
sense that this is
time has stopped that there's a sense of
History pausing and something very very
significant is going to be happening and
is it history setting is this the the
molten lava of History before it turns
into
Iniesta absolutely uh this will I'm sure
in 50 years time people will say this
was the end of that second World War era
Britain as clearly one of the great
powers on Earth with its Empire
extending after the second world war its
prominence in world history the question
is where is Britain going to go now and
can Charles lead us there will he be
allowed to lead us there will it be just
be something for prime ministers or
perhaps perhaps will we see the Prime
Minister and the Monarch work in tandem
to find a new role for Britain Sir
Anthony seldom thank you so so much well
let's uh return now to Central London uh
Buckingham Palace my colleague Anna
botting is there
thank you and I'm joined by Sky's Royal
commentator Alistair Bruce and the
former cabinet minister Lord botang
welcome to both of you
um a minute silence then Alistair are
coming together for the nation and three
cheers as dermit was mentioning much of
what we've seen in tribute to the queen
has been thankfulness at her life and
gratitude for her service
well from the point where she became
Queen she was well used to going to
observe the two-minute silence every
year at the cenotoff for the soldiers
Sailors there men and women and others
who had laid down their lives in two
world wars and she'd watched her
grandfather doing it her father doing it
and I think it's very poignant that
today
we've done it for her
and it's a big day tomorrow for the
nation the last occasion when the United
Kingdom will wrap their former Sovereign
with all the Splendor they can provide
and to start that with this one minute
silence and those wonderful reactions
the great thing and I think we've seen
this throughout the United Kingdom in
the last few days people will react how
they want to and this is catalyst to all
sorts of things we don't always know
what it is catalyst for
but in reflection it certainly has set
the tone for tomorrow's dignified and
ceremonial events
history making moment this may well be
uh Lord botang but for someone like you
who first saw the queen age 10 in Ghana
and what do you think when you you watch
on and and see Britain's place in the
world now and and what might happen next
well first of all I mean I reflect on
the Queen's the late Queen's life and
what it meant to so many people not just
in in this country but but globally and
there was I mean the Anglican communion
and she's head of the Church of England
the Anglican communion is a global
phenomenon so you will find in Anglican
churches all over the world this sense
of loss on the one hand Hope on the
other and this this sentiment I mean the
the hush here was almost tangible wasn't
it and then a spontaneous
um emotion of appreciation and we had a
similar thing just the Friday after uh
the late Queen passed my wife and I
liked so many others wanted to lay a
floral tribute and we were just outside
the gates of Buckingham Palace here and
we'd put our flowers down and we
happened to do so at the same time as a
group of people who we we later learned
were from something called Christians
and entertainment and they'd come
together because of the Queen's
involvement with the Royal variety shows
and the philanthropy for retired and
artists and after they'd laid their
flowers and after it laid hours suddenly
they began to pray
a prayer of thankfulness and everyone
around including us just joined in with
them and there was this this is this
spontaneity of of appreciation and
warmth now
that's going to linger
but what will follow I don't think will
be something that will in any sense be
negative or backward looking people will
look to the future of the Commonwealth
and a new king a a a new generation and
they will look to see Britain in that
context and they will still be this
sense of appreciation this sense that
our monarchy has a power to convene that
is not matched by any other so I'm
hopeful I'm hopeful and I believe King
Charles when you look at his engagement
with the environment uh with climate
change within with inclusive inclusivity
with religious freedom all those things
these are sentiments that people feel
today and they are relevant
as we watch those pictures still from
Westminster Hall and the queue's still
outside
um whatever does come next the monarchy
um could not have had a better platform
if I can put it like that for for what
happens with King Charles
well the institution is part of the
settled arrangement in the United
Kingdom and when the queen died
her son became king we found out he
wished to be called Charles he's now
Charles III we've seen what actually is
quite dull but the procedural processes
through which the Constitution at the
accession council and then in Parliament
make so what has naturally happened and
now we are in the process of mourning
which will end
on the morning after the funeral
tomorrow say it is a process but the
institution is there because there is a
settled view that it should remain there
and it's up to the United Kingdom we are
a democracy and I think the king is set
to supporting whatever we where he can
and I think watching him and his sister
and brothers coming out to pay their
respect to their mother has been part of
it all really it's a more a sense of
focusing every one of us if we're lucky
has had a family or a relation or a
friend who we've loved who's died and
people felt they knew the queen and
through this family the United Kingdom
as law boating says you know they are a
convening power for the United Kingdom
which it's up to our political
leadership to decide how to use in a
constructive way for us all that's down
to politics and the King made it quite
clear when he was in Barbados and my
wife wife and I were there just just a
few weeks ago but the king made it clear
that he was relaxed and perfectly
content with the decision of of
countries which were previously
Dominion which were previously
territories which were previously
countries which saw the queen as as head
of state perfectly relaxed about them
becoming countries led by presidents
because if that was their choice fine
and the people of Barbados although they
now have a president rather than the
governor general still have this sense
that the royal family is relevant that
Britain is a part of their history and
yes that history has had its ups and
downs that history is is complex life is
complex and we have in Charles III
someone who's quite capable of managing
that complexity of that I'd No Doubt and
I've seen it in practice when he's been
to Brixton when he has when he's been
present in places where yes there have
been issues around race and equal
opportunity which have been challenging
he has been there bringing people
together with practical projects around
the prince's trust around his
championing of of a multi-faith
democracy these are things which he
knows and understands and where he will
be able to make a real contribution I've
got no doubt about that
thank you both
well the queen consort has recorded a
personal tribute to the lake Queen
recalling her wonderful blue eyes and
saying I will always remember her smile
in the interview Camilla speaks of how
Queen Elizabeth carved out her own role
for many years in the difficult position
of being a solitary woman in a
male-dominated world
she has been part of our lives forever
I'm 75 now and I can't remember anybody
except the queen being there
it must have been so difficult for her
being a solitary woman
there weren't women Prime Ministers or
women presidents um she was the only one
so I think she carved her own role
she made a rule that she had her private
time and her private passions and then
her public role and I think that is very
important that you know the diary is
planned out so you know when you're on
duty and when you've got to do things
and then when she went up to Scotland in
August you know that was the moment
where it was her enjoyment
although she was probably working you
know with her red boxes throughout she
could have a family to stay as she could
do the same because she loved
[Music]
her real passion was racing
she was able to escape to Sandringham
she had to stop next door she could go
every day see her foals work out you
know the next meetings for the year
I think she always kept that as you know
her private pit
you wouldn't dare question her or argue
with her on how a horse had bred or how
it ran because she would get a very
Steely blue-eyed look back again
[Music]
current size go to Windsor the day I got
married
um
when I probably wasn't firing on all
sits and it is quite nervous and for
summer no reason I put on a pair of
shoes and one had an inch heel and one
had a two inch Hill so I mean talk about
hop along and there's nothing I could do
it's halfway done in the car before I
really and you know she she could see it
she laughed about it and said look I'm
terribly sorry and she did you know she
had a good sense of humor
I've taken her to some of my Charities
and to the ebony Horse Club
add to the medical detection dogs and
she loved both of them you know it was
real sort of genuine enjoyment and she
asked lots of questions and it was very
nice to take her to things which I I
knew she would enjoy
[Music]
it's wonderful blue eyes
that when she smiles you know they light
up her whole face
I'll always remember that smile you know
that smile is Unforgettable
[Music]
and Alistair that electric smile we saw
in the week that she died did we not and
we'll always remember that I think but
how important will the queen consort be
to King Charles
absolutely vital
the King has a very lonely role because
just as the queen found you know you'll
never you're never in a position where
you find you're equal you're always in
this elevated position
and everybody needs to be kept in
Balance when in such an elevated
leadership role
and just as Prince Philip used to be
brilliant with the queen and tease her a
level and support her an absolutely
robustly defend her so I think the queen
consort will do exactly that for King
Charles and they've obviously got the
most lovely
closeness
and I know from my own life and I'm sure
you and anybody else watching from
theirs if you do benefit from that in
your life you're Jolly Jolly lucky and
it does keep you centered and if the
role of the king is to provide that deep
Keel in the stormy seas of time then
he's going to want someone who is his
Keel too and clearly the queen consort
delivers that in spades
Alistair thank you now then earlier this
afternoon President Biden was one of
those who went to see the queen as she
at lay and stayed at Westminster Abbey
he said afterwards that she communicated
dignity and above above all a notion of
service well let's bring in our
International Affairs editor Dominic
wycorn and President Biden at one of
more than 500 foreign dignitaries
Dominic the biggest International Event
ever to take place in the UK or probably
anywhere and who've been at Buckingham
Palace this evening
foreign
yes and he had words of advice and I
think consolation for King Charles uh
Joe Biden of course who's been no
stranger to tragedy himself having lost
several members of his of his family and
he said to uh in these words of advice
publicly he said that the queen will be
with King Charles uh beside him
throughout uh the remained of his life
as you say Joe Biden is one of a hundred
heads of government being gathered uh
here I think it's fair to say that
there's never been such a concentration
of head to government and royalty and
foreign dignitaries before the closest
it comes to it is Nelson Mandela's
memorial service so back in 2013 whether
I think more than 50 head to government
well this is going to see double that
number gathered for the funeral uh
amongst them an emperor Sultans Crown
princes Grand dukes and of course
presidents and the big challenge for
officials is what you do with them how
do you get them to Westminster Abbey
behind me the solution to that is to to
hold them all in a kind of holding pen
if you like in in Chelsea Royal Chelsea
hospital and then to bust them here so
that would be a novel experience I think
for many heads of government amongst
them will be president Paula May Winks
who's the president of Trinidad and
Tobago who I interviewed earlier and she
told me how she would feel emotionally
during the funeral and she also talks
about how this is the end of an era but
the beginning of a new one and for the
Commonwealth in particular she says this
is an opportunity to bring about change
and she predicted that the process we
saw under Queen Elizabeth of countries
in the Commonwealth becoming Republic so
no longer regarding the British monarch
as the head of state that process she
says will accelerate
your Excellency looking ahead to
tomorrow the funeral that you'll be
attending
what will be your thoughts and memories
of the queen as you sit there in
Westminster Abbey through that service
well my most recent memory will be the
one when I met her around mid-may
as the Trinidad and Tobago defense for
steel ban played in for her in a private
performance which I attended
and she and I sat together and spoke
about the steel but on a few other
things in a short meeting of maybe 15
minutes or so
she was just so gracious not pretentious
at all
so that I perhaps was a little
anxious knowing that I was meeting Queen
Elizabeth but the minute she came out
and started speaking to me all the
anxiety went and it was just like
meeting an old familiar what was her
relationship would you say with Trinidad
and Tobago how did she
how does she regard your country
well she was our head of state until
1976 when we became a republic and so
they were very close ties with the
country
when she was there in Shogun she spoke
of her fondness for Trinidad and Tobago
and he was our national motto together
we Aspire together we achieve as a text
for her address then I think that she
held the Trinidad and Tobago as the
Caribbean and more so if not all of the
commonwealth countries in high regard
and one thing that has been changing of
course is is more and more countries
have been following Trinidad and
Tobago's lead going from Commonwealth
Realms to republics is that something
that's going to speed up do you think
now is is a is there pressure amongst
countries particularly in the Caribbean
to follow that lead
well a number of Caribbean territories
have expressed their inclination to do
so Jamaica Belize Antigua and Barbuda
among other Commonwealth Nations around
the world there is a feeling now after
all these years that The Sovereign
should really be the people
and that to have a sovereign from a
country that is far removed not only
geographically but culturally
right might not necessarily be the best
thing at this time of the nation's
development
so I think that perhaps the process will
begin speeding up in various territories
not particularly because Queen Elizabeth
had died but because that's just the way
a lot of the world is moving now
what will be your emotions what what
will be going through your
your mind as you sit in the Abbey
tomorrow looking back on the era
that this was bound to come
it's sad because
the queen has died
but things must change
and so this might be a juncture
for a small shift
and perhaps one that will gal upon
in time
personally
even though I only met the Queen Once
she felt
I wouldn't say an old friend
but because she has always been there
and represented to a great extent
even though
we were or we are a republic a certain
stability reliability a grounding
and
that has shifted from on us
the Commonwealth
on the whole
on a personal level I suspect I shall
shed a tale or two I was looking on the
television and so
her grandchildren standing
vigil
around her coffin
and it was so touching you know and I
thought well I really would have to
carry my handkerchief with me because
it's quite possible that I initiated
here
for the queen
the president of Trinidad and Tobago
well now this afternoon prince Andrew
paid tribute to the queen he called her
mummy and said I will forever hold you
close to my heart on Friday he was seen
again in military uniform as he stood
vigil with his siblings over the Queen's
coffin at Westminster Hall well I'm
joined Now by our Royal correspondent
Laura bundock and Laura what else did
the Duke of York say it's an interesting
statement for many reasons I think it is
the last of the Queen's children to make
a statement and he is the only one of
them who has used the word mummy which I
think is in itself interesting and if
you look at the photo I think that he
released accompanying the statement I
think it is the most intimate image
we've seen this picture in black and
white taken in 1960 by the society
photographer Cecil Beaton and you see a
queen there cradling very closely a
newborn Andrew as I say it could not be
a more intimate photo and let's just
have a look at some of the words he said
in the statement as well I'll read you a
small section he said Mommy your love
for a son your compassion your care your
confidence I will treasure forever I
have found your knowledge and wisdom
infinite with no boundary or containment
I will miss your insights advice and
humor as our book of experiences closes
another opens and I will forever hold
you close to my heart with my deepest
love and gratitude and I will tread
gladly into the next with you as my
guide again such a very personal tribute
and a real sense of his personal loss
but let's not forget we haven't really
seen much of the Duke of York he's
stepped down from all his Royal roles
back in 2019 and the queen stripped him
of those honorary military titles after
his friendship with Jeffrey Epstein it
was only the beginning of this year that
he settled out of court the sexual
assault case brought against him by
Virginia Geoffrey charges he always
denies but we know there was an
undisclosed sum involved and a very
significant Psalm and it was exceptional
almost to see him wearing military
uniform for that special circumstance in
the vigil what can we read into this
statement well I think it's certainly
perhaps an attempt at maybe looking
towards Rehabilitation into some kind of
Royal role that ultimate decision will
not rest with with the King and who
knows what the future will hold for him
Laura many thanks Laura bundock our
Royal correspondent there well let's
listen now to the Queen's first public
speech it was back in 1940 a radio
address to the children of the
Commonwealth many of them living away
from home of course be costs of the
outbreak of the second world war and to
one of our last appearances well on
television earlier this year during the
Platinum Jubilee
thousands of you in this country have
had to leave your homes and be separated
from your fathers and mothers
My Sister Margaret Rose and I feel so
much for you
as we know from experience what it means
to be away from those we love most of
all
to you living in new surroundings we
send a message of true sympathy and at
the same time we would like to thank the
kind people who have welcomed you to
their homes in the country
ah
never mind
[Music]
um perhaps
he would like a marmalade sandwich
I always keep one for emergencies
so do I
I keep mine in here
later
well I'm joined now by the author and
contemporary historian Sir Anthony
Selden that is so Anthony I mean what do
we make about 82 years apart of course
but what do they tell us about her
majesty the Queen's Evolution well she's
a great actress
had she not had another job she could
have had another career but it also says
I mean seriously it speaks of her deep
Humanity that we saw even on those
that early was she 14 15 young teenager
yet she was able to empathize with the
experience of many frightened young
teenagers and younger than teenagers
going out leaving their their homes
worried about what would happen to
family Left Behind she's identifying
with them and she gives you the feeling
that she understands highly emotional
and intelligent even at that age and
she's even thanking those people who are
hosting uh the the those who are coming
out of the city centers where their
risks of bombs and then straight The Way
Forward she's still got that same
ability to to speak to people of all
ages children with Paddington but also
you know it is a remarkable ability to
be able to communicate with and delight
and entrance people
I mean that's a magician over 82 years
separating those uh appearances
performances absolutely astonishing so
Anthony Sheldon thank you very much
indeed well let's return from here uh
Windsor Castle to Buckingham Palace and
uh annaboting is there and Anna can tell
us of course about those huge queues
still building to enter Westminster Hall
indeed so in fact no sign yet that they
will close the queue perhaps literally
get Peter out certainly people once
again beginning to queue through the
evening possibly overnight as you can
see this is Victoria Gardens as it leads
into Westminster Hall this alone has
taken some hours for people but these
people will be grateful that they will
be allowed to continue uh to queue the
suggestion had been very early today in
fact that people should uh not leave
home and not join the back of the queue
which is certainly coming further
forward I understand except to take
modern now as well on the South Bank of
the river so certainly the queue seems
to be shortening as I said no sign they
will actually close that queue and uh
once again as we've seen the Persistence
of people trying to get into Westminster
Hall where a short time ago we saw the
French President Emily macro and his
wife Brigitte the latest of a long line
of world leaders who have uh come to see
her majesty lying in state
that of course ends at 6 30 tomorrow
morning more people as you can see
coming through
while we are on the eve of the first
state funeral in more than half a
century it will offer a sense of history
and continuity involving traditions and
riots that have evolved over Generations
the funeral of Queen Elizabeth II will
be held at Westminster Abbey the resting
place of monarchs and the traditional
site of State funerals for centuries
ahead of the service a funeral
procession will escort the Queen's
coffin to The Abbey from the houses of
Parliament where it has been lying in
state
the coffin draped with the Royal
Standard will be born on the state gun
Carriage of the royal Navy
the Royal Marines will lead the
procession around Parliament Square
behind senior members of the royal
family including her children and the
King will be accompanied on the journey
to the Abbey by the sound of Mast pipes
and muffled drums
the procession will enter the Great West
door of Westminster Abbey at exactly 11
o'clock marking the start of the funeral
service
the queen will be carried past the grave
of the unknown Warrior and down the Nave
of the Abbey
following as they pass under the ornate
gilded entrance to the choir will be the
Archbishop of Canterbury and other
senior clergy
and then the coffin followed by the king
and senior members of the royal family
will be taken to the very heart of the
Abbey and placed in front of the high
altar
members of the royal family will be
seated alongside
behind them in the South transept heads
of state leaders and royalty from around
the world
sitting opposite holders of the Victoria
and George crosses their counterparts
from the Commonwealth and members of the
nation's highest orders of chivalry
while the Prime Minister former Prime
Ministers and the leaders of Scotland
Wales and Northern Ireland will sit in
the Abbey's choir stalls
the dean of Westminster will lead the
service
lessons will be read by the Prime
Minister and the Secretary General of
the Commonwealth the sermon will be
given by the Archbishop of Canterbury
at the end of the service the last post
will be sounded from the gothic Splendor
of the lady Chapel resting place of
kings and queens including Elizabeth the
first going back 700 years
a two-minute silence will be observed
throughout the United Kingdom before the
Ravalli is sounded by trumpeters of the
household Cavalry and in the Abbey the
national anthem is sung
the Final Act in the service will be a
procession of the Queen's coffin back
through the choir and along the Nave out
of the Abbey and back onto the state gun
Carriage before it is taken to Windsor
and her final resting place
well I'm joined once again by Sky's
Royal commentator Alistair Bruce rear
Admiral Jude Terry from the Royal Navy
and by the former cabinet minister Lord
botan welcome back to both of you
um Aleister first of all let's just
reflect that we are blessed with these
extraordinary buildings
um
to
this way well Westminster Abbey is
profound it used to be called the Paris
Church of the Empire it's certainly the
Parish Church of the kingdom and it does
that by containing first of all Edward
the confessor's tomb he was the patron
saint of English kingship and it is
filled with former sovereigns and also
Mary Queen of Scots
and it was where the queen came in 1953
to be crowned she obviously had got
married there too
to Prince Philip and so I think for the
queen it was a special place now Henry
III built it
to be that little bit taller than the
French coronation church which which was
at Rance and that's why it's so high it
was literally built almost ridiculously
to make it just that little bit bigger
and it's designed on a cross so that the
central area called the lantern which is
where we will see the queen placed on a
catapult during her State funeral is
visible by so many more people which
makes it ideal for tomorrow's event more
people can take part and it is the
traditional place as you you said for
Royal weddings and Royal funerals but it
it's it's full isn't it and at some
point they had to to go elsewhere
effectively which is I I guess what's
happened with Windsor it's during the
Hanoverian time they decided to build
their Royal vault at Windsor that too
filled and during the Queen's Reign she
built a special
place for her father and mother and it
will be there ultimately tomorrow after
the state funeral the service of
committal in sir Georgia Chapel tomorrow
evening the royal family will gather and
the queen will be interred with the Duke
of Edinburgh where King George VI and
Queen Elizabeth the Queen Mother now lie
rear Admiral let's talk about some of
those individuals who will take part
tomorrow Rick Pride we've talked already
it's an honor certainly for for all of
them but there's Royal Naval ratings
whose job it is to both pull and break
um the Royal gun Carriage I mean how how
difficult is that first of all so the
gun Carriage uh weighs approximately 300
kilograms um on its own so um you know
that is already an enormous weight
um the other thing to be aware of is
that all the people the 98 people who
will Who will pull the carriage and the
40 people who will be the break and the
guard officers with them led by
Catherine Jordan and they will um they
only came together last Saturday
and so we have trained them they have
worked really hard
um to build a team to understand how
they move and of course
um they did that and we had a rehearsal
in Collingwood on Tuesday but of course
the real test was at the early morning
rehearsal which you you covered as they
managed to work with the Bands with the
uh the Army uh with the RAF contingent
with the Commonwealth soldiers uh and
sailors and Airmen in order to try and
make that better so so they've been
practicing on their own they've built an
amazing team it's incredible to watch
um one of the people pulling the the
state gun Carriage his grandfather
pulled the state gun Carriage uh for uh
the Kings uh the previous King's funeral
um and so those are real history moments
um we've also got a number of people who
are taking part and it will be their
last act in uniform to be able to say
goodbye to the lady we all called the
boss and so they are incredibly
privileged and some of the stories of
just watching The Pride on their faces
uh is immeasurable and I think
particularly having come for the early
morning rehearsal it really dawned on a
lot of them the eyes of the world are on
them but ultimately for them it's about
their own individual Pride the ability
for them all to reflect and say thank
you and and to do our service her
majesty and His Majesty proud
so the extraordinary and historic
Westminster Abbey the practice and
detail of the military and then we come
to those who are the congregation
including those world leaders the
suggestion is that this will be the
biggest Congregation of world leaders
that human history has ever seen
well it certainly will be one of the
biggest with a specific purpose which is
to honor her late Majesty that's what's
brought them together in this act of
spiritual remembrance and of course the
Abbey has a particular connection uh
with the world of politics I mean it's
juxtaposition physically with Parliament
the links between those who serve as
clergy in the Abbey and our fellowship
as Christians in Parliament are well
known the speakers chaplain very much
part of that group of clergy people with
within the Abbey and it's it's symbolism
of the Commonwealth too because that's
where the Commonwealth day service is
always hell that was something very dear
to her late Majesty's heart she was
always there other members of the royal
family always there too to celebrate and
commemorate the Commonwealth so it will
will be an event that is yes religiously
and spiritually symbolic but also deeply
politically relevant as well Lord
Boateng rear Admiral Jude Terry and
Aleister Bruce thank you
I will miss her hugely the heartfelt
words from the Archbishop of Canterbury
as he prepares for his role at the
Queen's State funeral Justin Welby also
told me that world leaders should learn
from Queen Elizabeth's example he will
give the sermon in Westminster Abbey
tomorrow in front of a global audience
which could reach billions
we would all prefer that this had not
happened but it's a huge privilege to be
able to take part in this focused on the
family first
I know you've been down to see the
crowds queuing it outside Westminster
hall for example you know is is there a
shared experience we're having here oh
yes
yes yes yes I think it is a genuinely
shared experience it's an experience of
grief for many deep grief
but also mixed with an experience of
immense thankfulness
do you get the sense at all that she's
just leaving us at just the just the
wrong moment as we head into this
difficult winter which many people are
frightened about
um I think people are very frightened
about the future
and for many we mustn't forget you know
we've had 10 days of mourning but that
hasn't brought more money into people's
pockets
people are still going to food banks
during this time
struggling to work out
how to make the budget
last make the pay last as long as the
month
the extraordinary thing about the Royal
Family
is that they knew that
and the next few months may be very
difficult many many people will be
but from the point of view of the head
of state there's been a seamless
transition there's not going to be a gap
there there will be the hardship but
there's not going to be the gap
when was the last time you saw her it
was end of June early July and her
memory was so acute her observation so
perceptive
you got the benefit of 70 years of
accumulated wisdom
not only her family but I think every
senior politician every
Archbishop will will will mess up you
sound like you will after hugely we will
watch all these people arriving from
around the world on Monday and there is
a sense even now that she's unifying the
globe in this don't you think yes she's
going to unite more global leaders
possibly than at any point in human
history
and that is
perhaps a moment I hope and pray that
where they will
reflect on their own leadership
whatever their faith are you saying that
they could learn from her oh absolutely
I hope they find what they hear and see
and think about
a moment where they say to themselves
I would really like people to look on me
in the way that they look on her
we know they should be buried alongside
her late husband she'll be reunited with
her family her father her mother her
sister who are a tight-knit family did
she really believe that she would see
them again
yes
she was
a deeply faithful and Faith filled
under monsterative
quiet
Christian who trusted
in the faithfulness of God
is she at peace now yes
and should the nation take comfort from
that
I think the nation should take hope
not just comfort
but hope for themselves
well I'm joined by Sky's Royal
commentator Alistair Bruce and our Royal
correspondent Rhiannon Mills and indeed
an artist but we'll come on to that in
just a moment but Rhiannon first of all
can I just um ask you
um
we've seen so much activity have we not
not least at Buckingham Palace behind us
but tomorrow the focus goes back both to
the queen and to her family who are
grieving it's amazing seeing all of the
crowds camping out already down the mall
and I couldn't help but think about the
fact that it was only what three months
ago that we were here for the Platinum
Jubilee and again the queen
in death now is bringing people together
and and it's an interesting atmosphere
out there I think there is and we've
seen this all week I think there is
there's a sadness but also a lightness
and a sense of tomorrow yes for all of
the the pageantry and the military
display and the no doubt very somber
moments that we'll see in the funeral I
think there will be a sense of
Celebration as well and I think that'll
be fascinating to see as the day unfolds
of course as you said we had that
enormous Gathering of world leaders
probably the biggest diplomatic
reception ever held at Buckingham Palace
and of course the King's first but you
can't forget that the family were there
again around the king he's had to step
up and I think the whole family are also
showing that they are stepping up
alongside him as well he needs their
support at the moment getting the tone
right was always going to be really
difficult
um In This Moment we've had more
tributes today the likes of prince
Andrew saying he will always remember
the Queen's love of a son of course he's
had his difficult times also the new
Queen consort as well reflecting on the
Queen's sense of humor how much she
loved Balmoral so a poignancy that she
she passed away there and tomorrow we
will see again the family very much
front and center of the proceedings and
the funeral and I think again reflect
back on what a difficult week it has
been for them despite the fact that they
have wanted to share their moment of
grief so publicly
Rhiannon thank you very much indeed and
once again we see those people um paying
tribute taking a moment about perhaps in
this extraordinary atmosphere we've seen
in Westminster Hall
but let's bring in now at Ralph heiman's
uh Portrait Painter who had the honor if
I can say that of uh of painting the
Queen's Diamond corrective UEFA wrong
Jubilee official portrait
um how did it come about first of all uh
originally through the Australian High
commission uh a proposal was put forward
and 10 months later we we had a yes
so it was extraordinary so it turned out
that it was the only portrait she sat
for during her Diamond jubilito became
the Diamond Jubilee portrait which was a
remarkable opportunity well there it is
and there you are by it and it is huge
it has to be said it is it's nine by 11
feet I think it's the largest official
portrait of the queen
um but that was really for expressive
purposes to to show her amongst the the
vastness of the Abbey to to represent
her singular existence really how you
know the burden of offers that she you
know that she she must have you know had
and uh and the a reminder of where she
was physically crowned 60 years earlier
and Alistair you had something to do
with Ralph's choice of where he should
cite the queen in this portrait well
Ralph and I had quite a chat didn't we
indeed and I I've always loved the idea
of the place of Coronation Where it All
Began yes and of course it's very ironic
that it's there again in Westminster
Abbey tomorrow where we will all have
our eyes but for you taking on that
building it was remarkable but I think
our conversation where you describe some
of the deep historical significance of
the Abbey and the cosmatic pavement on
the high altar which is where the
coronation takes place and in particular
the the sacred geometry of that
extraordinary 13th century Mosaic and by
you know drawing my attention to that it
was a real inspiration for the portrait
but Ralph was marvelous because he knew
exactly how to capture her reflecting
and the point of the painting is if I
get this right that she's she's
reflecting upon the past the present and
in those days the future and of course
in a sense we now know the end of the
story yes but there's still a profound
nature to the close-up of the painting
as well as there is from a distance
that's right it was very important that
uh for me that there was a sort of very
reflective tone in this portrait
and so getting that particular pose was
quite a challenge during the sitting and
I asked Alice said to accompany me at
the city which was which was very
helpful and so Alistair you wanted the
queen to look down so we decided that I
would sit cross-legged on the floor
and
I remember the conversation was about my
sixth great grandmother who was a
convict
who who went over to to Australia she
stole a horse and they thought she was a
man
and then they discovered she was a woman
and the queen was fascinated by the
story in fact I brought out of my pocket
a 20 Australian bill because my sixth
great grandmother is on it she's called
Mary Raby and she was the first
businesswoman in Australia so the queen
is actually if you look at the painting
almost perplexed to hear the story but
it was a very lovely moment wasn't it it
was it was it was very lovely and it was
during the sitting I think was you know
I
I had because she sat in Buckingham
Palace we had to sort of paint a visual
picture
and spoke about the gravity of the
moment where she would be standing on
the cosmati pavement to set the tone the
mood for the sitting so it was
remarkable
and tell us something about the clothes
that she is wearing because she was
closely involved and there was a lot of
discussion was there not with the palace
about what she would actually wear for
this uh for this portrait exactly so
there were some requests put forward
originally for the coronation robe uh
which I don't believe she's won since
the day of Coronation and we had a
response back from the palace saying
she'd like to think about the robe
overnight and discuss it with Prince
Philip which I thought was absolutely
lovely
and it was decided that she would wear
the robe of State the Parliamentary robe
that she also wore when she entered the
Abbey on the day of her coronation so it
was very relevant and it was remarkable
so she she was dressed as she is in the
painting during the sitting
which was extraordinary and I think you
had to go and collect her did you not I
was taken by the courtier to go and
collect the queen and she came out sort
of slightly holding up her dress with
the with the robe hanging off her
shoulders very heavy carried by one of
her Pages who we will see tomorrow in
the funeral procession and when she saw
me she said
never left her but it was a very moving
and you worked so quickly Roth yes I
think we even finished a little early
and there and I think she said that uh
that by finishing 10 minutes early she
had a little bit more time to walk the
corgis which she hadn't had a chance to
do for a while during the time of
Jubilee year because she was so busy
well wonderful Recollections from both
of you really really extraordinary but
uh you know that is it isn't it the
queen is perhaps the most painted person
in the world photographed to and we see
the scene there at Buckingham Palace the
lights on the royal family waiting for
what will no doubt be a very difficult
and testing day for them tomorrow
Rhiannon we've already seen them haven't
we over the days since the queen died
wanting to publicly share this moment of
grief we had vigils I was inside
Westminster Hall last night when we saw
the the grandchildren's vigil I was
commentating on radio and the the intent
silence in the hall is one thing but
then I think for those who are walking
past the grandchildren it did heighten
that sense of emotion and and I think in
a way we will see that again tomorrow
because again for the family it's really
important that just as they did in life
they are again going to be the next
scenes supporting the queen in death
they will be there behind the coffin
once again as we've seen them carrying
out that procession so many times
already
and accompanying her to Westminster
Abbey a place where they've spent happy
times together where they've had
celebrations together and and in that
moment I think coming together yes with
all of those world leaders but also I
think importantly reflecting on the
sense of service and Duty that the queen
passed on to the nation and you're going
to see that in the fact that you'll have
NHS workers in the procession you're
going to have members of her Charities
within the congregation and just as she
did for her Platinum Jubilee that
Milestone yes we were all talking about
her and what a remarkable range she'd
had but no for her it was about making
sure that communities were coming
together especially after the pandemics
celebrating the ways that people had
come together in the last couple of
years during those difficult moments and
we're going to see that I think tomorrow
in the service so yes for all of the
enormity of it the fact that this is
going to be such a spectacle the
military pageantry of State funeral that
we have never probably seen in our
lifetimes and the world will be watching
all of those world leaders there
But ultimately a family at the center
paying tribute to her service and Duty
Rihanna Mills Ralph heimens and Alistair
Bruce thank you very much indeed
well they are still queuing as you might
imagine the final hours of lying in
state
still the atmosphere in there
with respect
let's leave you now with some of these
sounds and images of the past 24 hours
two five
[Music]
it is pleased almighty God to call to
his Mercy our late Sovereign Lady Queen
Elizabeth II of blessed and glorious
memory
by whose deceased the crown of the
United Kingdom of Great Britain and
Northern Ireland is solely and
rightfully come to the Prince Charles
Philip Arthur George
three chairs for his majesty the king
may live in the United Kingdom or in the
Realms and territories across the world
and whatever may be your background or
beliefs
I shall Endeavor to serve you with
loyalty respect and love
as I have throughout my life
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
Her Majesty gave us 70 years what's
giving her nine hours that's nothing I'd
worked 21 hours for her when I was very
little me and my mom said we would come
to this my mom's passed away so I'm here
for her
have you been waiting long David
the wall
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here is a motto which has been borne by
many of my ancestors
I serve
there's words what an inspiration to
many bygone heirs to the throne when
they made their nighty dedication as
they came to manhood
I cannot quite do a baby but through the
inventions of science I can do what was
not possible for any of them
I can make my solemn active dedication
with a hell and powerlessly
I should like to make that dedication
now it is very simple
I declare before you all
my whole life whether it's been long or
short
shall be devoted to your service
and to the service of our great Imperial
family which we all belong
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
Elizabeth it